hello everyone will encourage the radio
show we just finished our wonderful
interview with joke and Biagio we're
outside of the stupid and we talked
about their latest film dying to do
Letterman and there were so many points
in the film that I enjoyed it was very
inspirational one of which really stuck
with me was what Brian Regan said the
comedian Brian Regan and he talked about
how with comedy sometimes you get too
much in your head and you worry about
what the audience thinks about you am i
funny will they like me is this guy
doing better do you two ever suffer from
that and I've heard a term in like
psychological circles or whatever it's
analysis paralysis so did the two of you
ever suffer from overthinking your ideas
for shows or what have you or blog posts
and it's thankful zoom that's some sense
I may be suffering analysis paralysis
right now I'm just think we absolutely
did you to each other you know you you
when you put so much of yourself into a
project and you're just you know you
care about the outcome so much you don't
want to mess things up and so it's like
okay I'm and we really looked at it from
every option if I really cut the scene
you know every possible have we looked
at the script you know in every in every
from every sort of angle and yeah it
happens all the time in a certain point
you have to go screw up deadlines we got
to do it let's trust we put in the hard
work and that the work we've put in is
good enough to get us to a point where
we're making the right decisions I think
it comes from a fear of failure you know
that's why you're like I don't want to
fail at this so let me think it over and
over
again so at a certain point I think what
we've learned 30 years is just you know
trust our gut you know or when it's
between one or the other like do we want
to do it this way or that way you know
what do we instinctively feel yeah and
what rhythm said in the movie that to me
is so poignant cuz he's saying to Steve
who's trying to get on Letterman he's
like look I think you should do what you
want to do when you think it's funny and
hopefully other people will do it
yeah we'll think it's funny as well
including the Letterman Show and I think
that speaks to all artists it's like at
a certain point you have to block out
all the other voices you know the voices
in your head the voices around you have
to go you know there was something that
originally drew me to this project or
drew drew me to this scene that I'm
cutting or to the script that I'm
writing I need to go back to that
whatever that is whatever that that that
feeling in my gut is I gotta listen to
that above everything else so at the end
of the day I think that the cure for
analysis paralysis is listen to your gut
I don't know yes okay listen to your gut
and so the movie took a course of what
five years to make okay and and over
that time I new distribution strategies
have changed so has your strategy
changed from when you originally made
the movie did you envision it going one
way and it ended up oh we didn't have an
ending to her movie you know we were
just following the story and we had no
idea where it was going
he was even gonna get on Letterman or he
wasn't he was gonna possibly die or you
know still live so we had no idea what
the ending was so as we were going you
know pretty much after that one year
mark that he gives himself we're like
okay we don't know how long this is
gonna take so let's look at some
financing and we looked at that point
and turning it into
a TV show so kind of like following his
journey but on a smaller you know weekly
basis and got some really good interest
there and ultimately it ended up not
going because people wanted to know our
ending you know what's the ending and we
had lots of companies come to us it's in
once you have your ending will give you
finishing class
yeah which to me honestly is kind of a
slap in the face look look I'm gonna
edit ER for fifteen years
I don't need your finishing funds I need
someone to believe in the story as much
as we do we're laying our life savings
into this we're gonna make this movie no
matter what but you know what that's
what independent film is all about right
it's about so analysis doesn't believe
in the story as much as you do so you
make sacrifices to get it done and for
us this was that movie and you know
speaking to your distribution question
that I need for a gazillion reasons I
can't go into details but we're having a
lot of exciting conversations right now
I will say though it's funny because I
think things have changed you know John
Reese's book think outside the box
office has become a Bible for a lot of
independent filmmakers and I do feel
like the mindset has changed I feel like
today as an indie filmmaker your first
thought is to self distribute I don't
think it was that way five years ago I
think today deciding to let a
distributor have a piece your movie is a
bigger decision than distributing the
movie yourself and so I'm excited that
we live in a time now where you really
can go out and if you have a great story
and a great movie you believe in find a
way to bring it to theaters and you know
listen to Steve who is the biggest
dreamer of all you know he basically
risked his life to chase his dream how
can you tell that guy we're not gonna
shoot for the moon with this movie you
know so I can tell you whether it's with
the distributor or whether it's on our
own we're taking them with me all the
way I don't care what it takes and I'm
just so happy and proud that somebody
who have already come out to show their
support for the movie and been really
engaging with us like real engagement
not the social media term engagement of
like we're after on tweet maybe someone
follows like we're having real
conversations with people that that want
to be a part of a movie that says hey
it's important to go chase your dreams
and we appreciate everybody who's helped
us in this past month
festivals so I get fired up about this
between that and the pepsin between my
passion for this project and the Pepsi
Max I just drink isn't anyone happy so
very passionate about social media I
know you probably both have opinions on
it tell us your feelings do's and don'ts
well here's you know we're so busy
festival it tries my poor wife crazy I
know you know by John Reese's you know
definition I'm the PMD you know I mean I
I basically forced us headfirst into
Twitter and blogging and my wonderful
wife supporting us on it and I'm glad we
did because a lot of people look at
social medias oh I gotta get you know a
million Twitter followers a hundred
thousand Twitter followers and I gotta
build up the numbers and for us it's
never been about that it's always been
about I want ways to read to meet real
people I don't have access to our lead
assistant editor Nate Orlov we hired off
a Twitter he was up there tweeting a
bunch of stuff I didn't understand about
Final Cut Pro and I know a lot about
Final Cut Pro so I just hired a new just
hired our new assistant editor off of
Twitter as well so I think that it's it
not only has it been a way for us to
find good qualified people we've we've
found interesting characters off of
Twitter and in Facebook so for us social
media really is about when people say
engage I really believe that it really
is about making real relationships I
mean we make you guys you know through
Twitter through the web you know we you
know Julie and Jessica Kenya's a fake
you know Gary King we haven't even met
in person yet but I feel like I know
them from all the conversations we've
had on Twitter these are real
relationships they're not just people
that we're using and abusing to have a
big Twitter number so I do think that
independent filmmakers need to make the
most of social media and I was surprised
when I started doing my research that
there weren't a lot of really great
tools there's some but I feel like
musicians have it all over filmmakers
right now when it comes to finding great
ways to engage with their fans and keep
in touch there's a lot of services out
there that are dear to ad musicians
we've reverbnation is like a crazy tool
for our musicians that even gives you
your own free iphone app you know fan
bridges gray Top Spin is great but a lot
of them are really geared towards
musicians so I feel like hopefully a
service is going to step up and fill
that void and in the meantime we're
trying to figure out what
our workflow is going to be and we're
looking at bambridge we're looking at
topspin we're looking at sprout social I
love just as far as being able to keep
track of everything that's going on and
actually responding to the people who
are having conversations with us which
is hard because you know we're doing
7:00 a.m. to 1:00 a.m. days yeah you
know on our shows there's not really a
lot of time yeah you have strong
opinions well I think I think it's an
easy way for us to stay in contact with
people and to connect with fans even
then we meet up the festivals and you
know new friendships you build you know
it's a little bit you know like saying
you know but why are you using email you
know what email first came out it was
just a faster way of connecting than the
US Postal Service I think Facebook and
Twitter not made it even easier than
email it's just you know it's a little
bit of a time suck sometimes yes and
that's where I serve I get I get upset
with this guy because we get back to
everything we have so much work to do
and yeah okay
you know disconnect just for a second
cuz we gotta get back to it that's hard
so I'm like oh my gosh these people
every time you somebody responds to us I
want to respond back because they're
taking the time to engage with us but
sometimes it's like we are shooting like
two television shows and a movie and
it's it's difficult so a lot of times
I'll be responding at like 1:00 in the
morning or just trying to let people
know listen I got it I appreciate it and
we're trying to follow back and you know
we try to do things on our blog like a
featured Kickstarter project that we
feature all you know a lot of the
filmmakers we've gotten the know try to
help them raise funds for their films or
try to point out other great things
going on in around the people we've met
via social media and I'd love to do more
of that our little blog joke and Biagio
comm is a very part-time blog I wish we
could write even more on it but when we
do we try to spotlight other filmmakers
and we try to share with people what
we're learning and I think that's what
engaging is all about it if we could
share something and we can learn
something back yeah I think it's like
anything new is we're all still trying
to find our footing in it you know like
what is the best way to spend their time
on it and how can we engage with the
people without it being a full-time job
there's some missteps every now and then
I'll be a video and you could be like
that videos coming down now
I see your point I'm not a huge fan of
the big news but I can't tell you what
yet videos yeah that's so much response
so I know we have we have this big
argument because like where we can't say
what Film Festival over in yet and so me
and Steve did this whole tease video and
a lot of people loved it and then like
her dad called me and was like I'm very
disappointed with this video you need to
know like what real serious people are
watching this and they're upset they're
not getting the information and I'm like
well we gave some information like we're
into more festivals we just can't give
away where it is yet so I think we're
pushing the limits here and they're
trying to figure out you know what's
engaging versus annoying sometimes me if
Steve may cross